800 masques de type ffp2 une centaine de
sur blues tout ce matériel est remis à
l'hôpital privé de l'ouest parisien
basée à trappes des équipements
nécessaires pour cet établissement pour
restructurer des stocks après une
période de tension ceci va permettre
notamment de donner à notre personnel
des masques que nous avions déjà pour
toutes les personnes qui vont venir pour
des consultations des visiteurs pour
ceux qui sont autorisés à rentrer ceux
qui ont des masques qui sont issus qui
protège certes tous ceux qui n'ont pas
de masque on a une certaine amélioration
on a un peu moins de patients kovy de
qu'au départ on sent que le pic diminue
après on reste vigilant parce qu'on a
toujours tous les gestes barrières et on
est en zone de confinement de toute
façon sur le territoire comme toute la
france donc on attend de voir un peu
comment le déconfinement va se passer et
on reste prudent moins de patients une
amélioration de la situation sanitaire
de son côté la région ile de france
continue de fournir des équipements en
fonction des besoins
chaque élu sur son territoire par la
région été mandaté pour prendre la tâche
des structures de santé dont j'ai eu le
directeur général kim a indiqué son type
de besoins plus précisément entre
chirurgicaux pas chirurgicaux et ffp2 et
puis ensuite la région a fait a prévu un
lot pour l'hôpital de trappes que je
suis venu apporter aujourd'hui dans
quelques jours des masques ffp2 seront
remis aussi au centre qu'ovide 10,9 de
la ville de montigny le bretonneux